my name is Christian Bale and I want you
to panic this Swedish teenager is being
credited with igniting a climate
revolution
first off let's take a look at her
credentials Greta tunberg first heard
about climate change when she was just
eight years old soon she'd convinced her
family to go vegan and to give up flying
she says that that gave her hope that
she could make a difference
Greta's Friday for future protests began
in August 2018 when she sat outside the
Swedish parliament on her own every
Friday
she'd been inspired by the March for our
lives protests where American students
led an historic march for gun control
many of you appear concerned that we are
at wasting valuable lesson time but I
assure you we will go back to school the
moment you start listening to the
Science Friday her future is now global
movement involving hundreds of thousands
of people taking to the streets Greta
has laid into some of the world's most
powerful people you lied to us you gave
us false hope and she practices what she
preaches a girl that has travelled a
great distance on a train from Sweden
but she says she's just a normal girl
who misses her sisters and her dogs and
she didn't start the climate revolution
she arrived at a time when it was
looking for a hero there from climate
activists for decades but something has
changed young protesters are getting
more and more attention here's why first
social media platforms have become
activists recruiting grounds
Greta's generation are known for being
more socially aware so they're already
primed to get on board and that has
become much easier to be a young climate
activist
the second reason is their message and
it's a scary one you told us that the
future was something to look forward to
no children I'm not even aware of fate
that awaits us young activists have
tapped into people's fear for their own
lives much more attention grabbing and
how bad climate change will be for the
planet and the third reason is their age
it's harder to ignore school children
that older more typical protesters the
image of hundreds of thousands of kids
coming together is a positive one and it
makes it much easier for everyday people
to get behind them and their queen she
says she's not a leader icon or face of
a movement I don't want you to listen to
me I want you to listen to the
scientists but that's what makes Greta
Sundberg a perfect figure head by
leading a movement that is now cool
among young people she's become a person
people can aspire to be she's become the
climate poster girl